I'll never forget seeing the Harlem
Globetrotters in Madison Square Garden
and to my right is a current member of
the Harlem Globetrotters in his 16th
season with said unit buckets Blake's
good to see you sir oh thank you thanks
for having me you bet
this what does it like to be a Harlem
Globetrotter it's an amazing feeling I
have an opportunity to wear this uniform
I wear it with a lot of pride my
predecessor is the goose Tatum's Marcus
Haines Meadowlark lemon now not curly
Neil's curly Neal yeah to me that him
Meadowlark lemon had been there for
quite some time when I started following
the Harlem Globetrotter curly Neal was
the guy to for me oh for sure and he's
still amazing he comes to our training
camp he does talks to us yeah gives us
some positivism encouragement lets us
know that the players of this era you
know the bigger faster and stronger more
dynamic not that they weren't for their
era but you know we got weight programs
diet programs got shoes modified and
made for specifically for basketball
they were playing in kids and then the
old Chuck's you know so um so he gives
us some great encouragement I think it's
pretty cool to have someone of his
stature come you know give us his
blessing so to speak and now you were
you're from Phoenix Arizona
yes Phoenix Arizona so when were you
first exposed to the home globe trotters
um actually I think I was about five
years old I got two older brothers so
you know some elbows going back and
forth while watching but then as I got a
little bit older maybe eight nine ten
yeah started paying more attention Wide
World of Sports on Saturdays and then
Scooby Doo of course and I think they're
all so sure yeah they were on it yeah
and I asked my coach uh sweet Lou Dunbar
he's a Globetrotter Legend I had to get
off the island I think he said some
about the Love Boat so the Love Boat
picking up from Gilligan's Island with a
hell of a show you know everybody's kind
of redoing things they might have to do
this so you must have gotten a kick out
of the Larry Nance moment at the slam
dunk competition where Jeff here comes
out in the Phoenix Sun uniform of dad
who is on
courtside when he did the same dunk that
his dad did definitely Larry Nance
senior was a phenomenal player for the
Phoenix Suns I followed the Phoenix Suns
quite a bit and then to have an
opportunity to watch his son be even
before Sun went to the NBA he was at
University of Wyoming where I also went
to college okay and Larry shiet who
brought me to Wyoming was also his son's
coach so I um you know come full circle
um I got a chance when he was a Laker to
go to Lakers practice and me and Larry
Nance Jr had a chance to talk and then
all of a sudden he's in a slam dunk
competition just like his dad like his
dad that Zach that really was really
neat I'm here with buckets Blake's
of the Harlem Globetrotters who also was
the MVP junior and senior seasons in
team captain of the University of
Wyoming back in so in 99 and 2000 yes
yes now when I was in school at Michigan
in 1990 that was Venice Dembo oh yeah
was that why Dennis Deming who's the
other one broccoli era Kleckner
Eric let me drop it on you right Reggie
Slater went there and Theo Ratliff those
are other two NBA players that were
after those okay did you have any NBA
aspirations yourself item you know what
um
you know what I did actually I am I
played after not getting drafted NBA I
got drafted in the CBA the CBA went
bankrupt and they start the d-league and
the inaugural season I played in the
d-league and after that I went to Europe
and then when I came back from Europe
the Globetrotter Scouts gave me a call
they're already in season they sent me
on a 10-day contract you can sign me
after six of those ten days and what the
best basketball decision I've ever made
I've been in 83 countries in my 16
seasons I'm on my third passport and I
get a chance to not only play the game
that I love but I have to I get a chance
to have a positive influence on kids we
have several community outreach programs
anti-bullying character education our
hospital visits are called the smile
patrol and we visit a numerous Boys and
Girls Clubs and YMCAs and rec centers
and talk to kids about our program
called spin which stands for some
playtime is necessary to encourage kids
to stay physically active that's
fantastic and folks here in Southern
California and Georgia last night in
Santa Barbara this
we're on in an Orange County big time on
the home of angels radio so folks it
where the Globetrotters are coming to
the Honda Center on Saturday tomorrow
and then in staples on Sunday Harlem
Globetrotters calm to find out when
they're coming to spot near you so let's
let's be honest here could a Harlem
Globetrotter win the skills competition
three-point contest and the dunk
competition could they have done that in
staples last weekend I'm pretty sure we
could you know we are some of the best
athletes in the world we got some of the
best shooters so let me break it down
this way we have 17 Guinness World
Records one of those Guinness World
Records was the most NBA three-pointers
made in one minute using one basketball
by one person and I have two teammates
tied for that that's aunt Atkinson and
Brawley cheese Chism they made 11
three-pointers in one minute getting
their own 11 NBA three-pointers or
getting their own rebounds and also they
not they beat Dirk Nowitzki and Kevin
Durant's record for the most NBA
three-pointers made using one basketball
with two players in a tandem so ok you
know so we can shoot and then our
dunkers are just phenomenal so we can
definitely want a slam dunk competition
and then I got my teammate hoops green
over there with some of the best
dribbling skills so the Skills Challenge
she can dribble pass and shoot and I
think that's pretty much what the Skills
Challenge is so ok I think hoops is
wearing a microphone over there so hoops
you you you back up what he is saying
right now definitely confident in myself
I think I can do it ok so you would win
the skills competition and immune be
all-star salary well in a couple minutes
we're gonna I'm gonna be part of Skills
Challenge Skills Challenge ok and how
you're six eight right I'm six eight but
I'm a little older now okay okay
but I went to university North Carolina
so I had a good chance to work out with
Vince Carter and dunks and all bunch of
fun stuff but that time so who was your
coach there which was it mean Smith
recruited me but he retired a
my two months after I got to school and
then I play for Coach cutters and Matt
Doherty okay yeah yeah so we got a
serious business yeah it is let him now
my coach my former coach at Wyoming
Larry shy it said uh he's uh with the
Dallas Mavericks right now so you know
we got some some good coaches behind it
okay now does anybody walk around and
say I'm a member of the Washington
Generals does anybody do that I'm
probably the Washington Generals I'm a
member of the Washington general do you
know what but they don't their asses
kicked all the time but they could shoot
the lights out and you know what they're
shooting for they're shooting for our
spot there's been in the past on the
Washington Generals used to be owned by
a guy named red clots who the only
Washington General actually have his
jersey retired by the way yes um I think
he hit the game-winning shot against the
Globetrotters in 1971 so we have lost of
the Washington Generals it wasn't our
fault we weren't born
I talked to curly and Meadowlark about
that but you know red clots there's been
some watched in general that have played
so well against us okay that they
actually became Harlem globe so if you
can't beat them join them
essentially yes yeah for them yeah for
sure no no your gum this is my sixteenth
season I think I've been holding it down
for quite some time she's assistant
seasons you're you're you're like the
Jamal Crawford of Carter okay look I
went to Michigan okay the Michigan
helmet we you know I think Crawford came
out in 2000 I'm a Jamal Crawford fan
don't get me wrong I like the way he's
right nobody understands insanity
zadofian story yeah but no he's a but
Jamal Crawford I mean I mean no one
wants to guard him but I don't think
anybody wants to guard me either so I
like it good
alright buckets Blake's everybody
fantastic and again Harlem Globetrotters
calm before we go and check things out
where we're gonna
I'll be part of a Globetrotter Maddox
our Magic Circle yeah for for even just
a split second the little kidding me is
just going crazy right now you have a
record yourself where you you made a
shot off of the building in San Antonio
the Tower of America's in San Antonio a
583 foot shot yes 583 feet and 8 inches
oh I'm sorry I mean it matters okay um
not that I'm afraid of heights but it
was my second shot for the next question
cuz usually that's what people ask okay
but it was pretty awesome the high shot
ever made in North America off the Tower
of the Americas in San Antonio Texas
oh my god it was pretty all down for the
radio audience were showing this yeah
yeah and it looks like it's spun back
into it right yeah it's nothing but well
my teammate did some research for me my
teammate Oh got over there it's called
the Magnus effect and did you learn that
at North Carolina Aldo well no actually
I was doing the research to break his
record so so the dynamics of it pretty
much I've taken a shot from 342 feet off
the gondola that takes you up to Stone
Mountain in Atlanta and when you that
was a little bit more scary because it
was dangling you know and the wind was
blowing oh yeah so if you finger roll it
and put front spin on it this direction
yes it goes underneath you the higher
you are and if you put backspin on it
like I did before that shot it goes in
front of you instead of underneath you
so you have to shoot it down because you
know it has that curve but the closer
you are to the basket if it's a hundred
feet it's more of a direct shot and you
made a 583 foot shot on your second my
second shot at 141 for two from that
line yeah you know what I don't know if
I'm gonna get back on that line I mean
that's that's that's incredible
so again go to Harlem Globetrotters calm
to find out where tickets
are available for purchase when the
Globetrotters come through your town
Thank You thanks for coming in bucket to
games on the 24th at the Honda Center
okay one game at Staples on the 25th
fantastic look forward to look forward
to that everybody in the area so stay
tuned for our next television only
segment where I'm gonna be part of the
Globetrotters Magic Circle
alright hang in here once again with the
Harlem Globetrotters buckets introduce
your teammates again for me please
now this is my teammate hoops green
Orlando Melendez but we call him el gato
Oh gato for our buckets all right and so
what would my what do I have to come up
with a nickname for myself or okay say
you're a whole name so I could just
Richard
Seth Eisen Richards Eisen what do you
think I should come up with here
double dribble Richie Rich no we call
them in your isin okay Magic Circle okay
and I'm and you showed me around the
back is one right okay so yeah okay do
you want me to show you a good short
again around the back there's one on my
leg is - yes fake pass fake three right
for his fingers in right in five is off
the knee let me just one more time this
this they pass back okay and then once
he gets it he does his thing it's a
little faster yeah okay a little better
oh my god
that's fantastic okay very good all
right get that good spin in all right
Wow and then you have let me see let me
see you're okay all right very good
yeah all right so let's get started Mike
hit it hit it hit the museum in your
Isaac well
you got diamond cutter baby one hand oh
my goodness fantastic Harlem
Globetrotters calm get your tickets to
see el gato buckets greatest dribble in
the world and in your face I challenge
piece of cake
so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience